ha sido un golpe definitivo contra la
política de cero covid que ha Regido la
vida de este país durante tres años y
que abre la puerta a la convivencia con
el virus un asunto que hasta hace sólo
una semana Será anatema la mayoría de
las medidas aprobadas hoy y habían sido
adoptadas por varias ciudades en los
últimos días para lidiar con más
realismo con los brotes descontrolados y
el hastío popular la novedad es que las
medidas ahora tienen alcance nacional y
han sido aprobadas después de la reunión
del poli buró de ayer que fue presidida
por schimping los contagiados
asintomáticos o con síntomas leves
podrán cumplir la cuarentena en casa es
un giro radical respecto al envío masivo
de contagiados y contactos a los centros
de cuarentena también han sido
finiquitados otros rasgos
característicos de la cero covid como
los test masivos o la clasificación de
zonas de alto riesgo con criterio
extensivo las pruebas pcr y sus
resultados negativos Ahora sólo tendrán
que ser registrados en hospitales y
escuelas ni siquiera será necesarios
para viajar por el país lo que se espera
que estimule el regreso a casa y el
turismo en el próximo año nuevo Chino
aquí en Pekín hace ya días que se vive
una situación inédita nunca habíamos
escuchado de ningún contagio en nuestro
círculo más cercano y ahora es habitual
que sean varios los contagios están
disparados Y es seguro que será muchos
más que las cifras oficiales Porque
muchos de los pequeñeces ya ni siquiera
se hacen las pruebas pcr
muchos han elogiado el final de la cero
covid otros en cambio Después de tres
años sin convivir con el virus están
asustados de hecho los supermercados se
ven muchísimo más vacíos desde que ya no
piden las pruebas pcr en la entrada